[Music]
so
do you guys believe that canada dry
actually has
ginger in it no real it doesn't taste
like it it has like medicinal properties
in it where you would buy this
to cure your ailment why is it even
called canada dry
my grandma swears by this by the way
when you have a sore tum-tum that's what
i've been told
if you ask a mexican mom she'll give you
the coca-cola or the 7-ups
have you ever tried like real like
ginger beer though it has way more bite
to it
compared very spicy it tastes like what
is this ginger ale
is that that's different your beer is
different so much stronger yeah like
canada dry is just like flavored like a
ginger beer but
but like without the ginger it's weak if
you've ever had ginger beer
everything after this week yeah it just
tastes like candy yes i'm a big canada
dry fan
i like it i love it but only when i fly
only why that's when i drink tomato
juice when you fly
almost exclusively mickey does that too
i love v8 but i just never have it
outside of a plane
and it's much better cold than room
temperature
i disagree i like i like it room temp
you know when i make uh virgin mary's i
make them with a spicy v8 base
and then i pour half a bottle of
worcestershire in there wow that's a lot
holy [ __ ] yeah no that's good it's good
i'll make you one
yeah i want one red lime so much love
have you guys ever drank v8 while eating
toast it tastes like pizza
oh pizza a pizza
a pizza or a piece of what a piece of
pizza pizza
i feel like any of those drinks have um
even v8 i feel like you'd be surprised
by how much sugar those
oh yeah oh my god dude yeah the sodium
is nuts i ain't the sodium but i love
salt i love
it's my baby is salt why people say
salt's bad
do you retain water there's too much of
it i guess sodium is bad for your heart
blow to some [ __ ] it's a good source of
iodine and apparently we need it
yeah that's why i eat a lot of salt wow
anyway back to canada dry here so
a class action lawsuit don't tell me
they're like there's no ginger in this
[ __ ] you call it ginger ale
that's exactly what happened oh no way
this man in canada in vancouver
he spent years buying canada dry
for his family based on the labels
promised that canada dry
is natural and made from real ginger
according to his claim is that what it
says
i have it at home too i don't think i
remember seeing that yeah well
apparently the label
says that and and so that's why he he
sued canada dry and
but it turns out that like once they
were looking into it
that canada dries ginger it's like so
diluted that but it really is made from
it
okay so what they do is they do buy
actual ginger but then they boil it in
ethanol
and that essentially destroys any
nutritional or
medicinal benefits according to one of
the lawyers here
and then they said that the ginger is
then turned into a concentrate
and then that is distributed into a
like they're saying that one drop of
this concentrate can fill 70 cans
holy [ __ ] so then there's like
barely any actual real ginger and even
if there is real ginger there's zero
benefits to it because it's so it's too
spency to put
put real ginger in there basically on
the label yeah
exactly i gotta find a lawsuit like that
where it's just out in the open waiting
i just gotta do a little bit of reading
pretty good label reading like does dr
pepper have pepper in it yeah
is it made by a doctor any doctor
there's no doctor in it
there's something out there there's no
doctor in there
but yeah so then this man was able to
reach a settlement for this lawsuit he
got
200 000 wow
good for him but his kids all got
diabetes so who's the real winner
yeah he was drinking it by the way it
was satisfaction for many many years
yeah like he likes he's like maybe what
it's not healthy
but if he got a real ginger ale drink he
would not like it it's gross
compared to ginger root has gotten so
much mileage
for being wheat so bad it's good in
sushi i'll take it as a
side dish of palate cleanser for sushi
but other than that bomb on top of
salmon though
straight it's pretty bomb too but the
bowls
yeah when they pickle it the red one i
do like a moscow mule though
with the ginger beer you do make it very
good you guys are proving me wrong oh
yeah
yeah we're getting smashed right in that
corner i chop it up into small
pieces and i eat it raw with my
dumplings he eats it raw oh wow
everyone here has proven in a thing that
they eat it has given me an example his
mom always buys this crazy ginger root
that she spends
so much money oh [ __ ] it never mind
think's bitter
my uncle mark is a uh thank you a super
diabetic
uh super diabetic like super ultimate
diabetic super diabetic
yeah yeah he um he's got a big d he has
to get he has to get it like
injections like insulin injections
everything like twice a week
uh and [ __ ] that's like blade but he
swears
he swears he doesn't need any of that
[ __ ] and when he first got diagnosed
with
diabetes they were like they were like
hey man um
you need to stop eating all the sugar
and all this stuff and he's like
[ __ ] i'm just gonna do ginger root
with tea
and then he slowly got more and more
diabetic
could you imagine going through
ginger root and t t that's all he did
yeah and he really thought it was gonna
it's like general but he was probably
still eating like [ __ ]
he was that's exactly it he was eating
like [ __ ] but as long as he added just
ginger root and tea to his
diet dumb because then if he only did
that then i'd be like really how do you
get more diabetic like where was the
sugar there what happened oh no
that guy still eats peach pie and [ __ ]
you know you know
i thought you couldn't cure diabetes but
um
my cousin helped his dad two types right
one of them is
is curable you're born with it yeah and
then the other one's self-induced or
you're pre-diabetic or whatever
most of the diabetes is because people
just eat too much damn sugar
but then my uncle got it and then he was
like my life's over man i got diabetes
and then my cousin's like
no i couldn't fix that and he basically
cured his dad
wow dying he'd lose yeah
diet a little bit of exercise exercise
diet and then he
put him on a strict like nutrition of
like it's pretty paleo
like but it's more like what do you call
it pescetarian but
high vegetable no carbs and then
he was like no wonder because he was
just watching his dad eat he goes you
eat like
three packs of instant ramen like you're
in college
and he's like 80. oh my god that does
sound delicious though it does
put an egg in it because that's a bomb
uh no he's he usually just eats like
fish but like he never really ate red
meat or any of that because he thought
that was unhealthy
but he's pounding down like for every
meal like three bowls of rice
and this guy can eat like we would go to
buffets and go like when are you gonna
[ __ ] leave dude because
he was that guy yeah he would eat
like a garbage disposal yeah but then
he actually cured it i was like what the
[ __ ] i didn't think that it was curable
well my dad got to the point where he
lost so much weight he got near his high
school weight
and he basically doesn't have to take
the medicine anymore like as much
nice so he was diabetic or he is dying
he's type 2 but he
he's not as severe get it way under
control yeah he says his feet his feet
still get numb though if he doesn't do
exercise regularly so he has to be all
over it you can lose a foot
yeah to gout right yeah yeah from
diapers yeah you just get like one tiny
scratch in your feet and you won't feel
it and then it gets infected and then
it's
it gets covered uncle had his leg
amputated from diabetes
i knew a guy who drank so much monster
energy drinks he got gout
[ __ ] it's like a uh your foot
swells it's like it's like the zero
joints you're it's like your body yeah
it's a form of arthritis
yeah wow isn't that crazy we have so
many diseases from having too much food
like having too much resources yeah yeah
that's the crazy part
where it's also like not having enough
to well having too much is like too much
meat
too much sugar right like obesity too
much
like abundance like it's like [ __ ]
weird like i got too many bananas so now
i got diabetes
we're at too much korean bbq and i got
gout or something you know it's crazy
well that's because the [ __ ]
way that they did the food table in like
the 80s and 90s
was like totally done up by the dairy
industry and all these other cats so
and big in the meat industries what's
the new thing then what is healthy like
what are we supposed to do
i don't know but they train generations
to eat like [ __ ]
yeah yeah and they have a new one for
the kids and i i saw it
but it's like it's the same pyramid but
at the bottom it's mainly like
vegetables
and then protein and then switched it
around and then there's no more
candy on there because they used to have
candy at the top do you remember that
yeah the guys who made the pyramids were
the ones selling us the
the wheat the bread all of it the sugar
industry
collaborated with the milk industry and
scientists by the way they literally
bought
off scientists and got them to provide
the studies that yeah
informed all this [ __ ] that's why i
don't believe in science nope i just
believe in me
i always deny the science yep that's the
way to go
you know they even had um doctors
per saying like yeah smoking once a day
is is good for you
yeah yeah yeah marshalls with money yeah
that's [ __ ] crazy so all the stuff
that we think is healthy
might be [ __ ] i don't know like our
phone we don't know we haven't tested
this [ __ ] enough we don't know what
it's doing to our body the ball cancer
maybe sorry i'll never stop using brains
absolutely if they said some [ __ ] like
that though how hard would it be to quit
using the phone
oh it wouldn't be that hard for me they
used to sell i don't know back in the in
the early aughts late 90s they would
sell like
cancer reducing things that you can put
over your farm
if you guys remember that because
everyone was worried about brain cancer
yeah
i do remember that before they sold
things these metal like sticker
bar cody things that they claimed
would reduce the amount of waves hidden
your brain are they made out of cow dung
because there's a new one that some
entrepreneur in india is
making these indian guys man they're
coming in they're taking our jobs
he's claiming to block the 5g waves from
your brain or some [ __ ] oh
yo isn't it crazy though like sometimes
you'll have these old people that are 90
something and they're still like eating
cupcakes and smoking up a storm and like
using the n-word
[Laughter]
but they're alive and they're they're
healthy and they're like
yeah and then you'll have these like fit
ass people
that die when they're 50. and from a
heart attack too like healthy-ass people
dying from
things that you wouldn't think they'd
die bench pressing too much
yeah i like when somebody's 105 years
old like what'd you do and they're like
cigarettes
and bacon every morning oh yeah all
right
cigarettes and whiskey that's my
breakfast i jerk off morning noon and
night yeah
maybe that feel excuse me
that's the dinner bill
[Music]
foreign